so we have been given a new look at
doctor strange and a multiverse of
madness in the form of two newly
released images from the film and also
some new information from an interview
so let's get straight into it so combo
batch promises it's a big big movie
whose doctor strange was last seen
hastily patching up the cracks in a
reality at the end of no way home it's
going to be an absolute riot no way home
and a double whammy of avengers infinity
war and end game prove that doctor
strange really does play will of others
after all and his second solo film finds
him teamed up with a comic book favorite
make way for america chavez a youngster
with the ability to navigate her way
through the various realities that make
up the multiverse strange is still
learning about the multiverse director
sam ramy teasers and he's a character
that can actually travel through it he's
an exclusive image of the pair having
seemingly been captured but by whom
beyond the chaos carnage and chavez of
it all through multiverse of madness is
a doctor strange story through and
through one that would drill down right
into the character's core there's a lot
of reckoning says cumberbatch and a lot
of self-discovery strange is almost a
stranger to himself before this film
unfolds and reveals what essentially is
in his nature that he then has to either
confront resist or fall into or become
the answers to the questions of who
strange really is won't have easy
answers there are some very bold ideas
and some extraordinary tests of strange
and encounters cumberbatch continues
there are some very unexpected
conclusions so it seems like we're going
to get a lot more character development
with doctor strange which i am glad
because after all this is his film it's
in the name doctor strange i know a lot
of people concerned that this movie will
be overshadowed by cameos and other
characters but from what we're hearing
here thankfully a big focus of this
movie will be on doctor strange and his
self-discovery and apparently we'll have
some very unexpected conclusions so i'm
really looking forward to what they're
referring to there and also we have the
two newly released images here the first
one being doctor strange and chavez
being captured so doctor strange and
chavez are both looking at each other
here perhaps they're trying to come up
with a plan on how to escape or perhaps
they're just figuring out where they are
or what's happened the second image here
we have doctor strange still kept
captive with his hands handcuffed now i
think this is just an alternative shot
of what we saw on the trailer where
professor x says we should tell him the
truth so good chance here doctor strange
is actually looking at illuminati here
or perhaps just um professor x in this
scene but only time will tell anyway
what do you guys think and if you
haven't already please like and
subscribe and turn notifications on to
show your support thanks for watching